hey will a biden nominee pay the price
for not being iowa nice
yes speaking your mind on twitterverse
can haunt you like a never-ending curse
i speak of beth pritchard gear yes that
beth pritchard gear there you are young
lady
she's biden's nominee to serve on the
board of directors of the tennessee
valley authority or tv
and is in the middle of confirmation
hearings senator jody ernst asked
whether civility is a fundamental aspect
of her role if she were confirmed
but like me at a sausage factory things
took a turn for the worst
i did that
do you believe civility is a fundamental
aspect of your role on the tennessee
valley board if confirmed absolutely do
senator yes and thank you for answering
those questions honestly and i think it
appears to be a recent sentiment
if you'll take a look at the tweet that
we also found so you can see that um
beth
gear tweeted out
at fox news and at senator joni ernst
hideous can you explain that tweet
i can't read it i apologize that's not a
way of getting out of answering the
question but what i just read it to you
well you said i heard that sorry
hideous
so what did beth think she was tweeting
about
and i get it
anyway joni wasn't finished
folks this tweet is from 2015.
i've heard a lot about tweets in the
former administration this is prior to
that
this is not iowa nice folks
even when they're mean they're nice
you know what else is in iowa nice
ninety percent of everything written on
twitter twitter brings out the bullying
people and turns us into nelson's and
everyone who disagrees with us milhouse
who hasn't said something mean on
twitter anyway
hey still on for brunch this weekend oh
yeah about that um 10 years ago did you
tweet hey man i hope you die in your
sleep in a house fire sorry that
offended you so brunch
that's the thing is like the next day
you wrote hey dude i hope an anvil falls
on your head and you drown in quicksand
so
my bad all right so brunch
oh
and then like the day after that you
wrote
hey man i definitely wasn't kidding
about you dying in a house fire getting
hit by an anvil or drowning in quicksand
yeah see you sunday bottomless mimosas
you know uh liz i
i mean look it looks kind of petty what
joni ernst did but i i was enjoying it
because i every everybody wants to be
able to be face to face with somebody
who trolled them years ago yeah yeah
that's right what a moment that was
right i mean yeah i mean what's the
shelf life on tweets you can carbon date
that one i think but uh you know so but
what what and she she caught her
flat-footed yes and by the way it was
about obama's state of the union address
so you know jeremy ernst go around
ripping up that address yeah it's true
but you know but but what's with her
qualified apology was a non-apology in
your opinion if you think i felt that
way you know what i mean so clearly she
doesn't care what joni ernst thinks but
you know this is for by the way the tva
this is for the only federally owned
utility i don't even know why we have
that and so what i'm thinking about who
is this person going over there is she
going to be some far left person who's
going to put the grid on i don't know
solar or whatever and you're going to
add more letters to tv a b c d
mean you know what i mean i don't know
who this person is but it wasn't what a
moment you you because you're right
there's so much bullying on twitter
there's you know they're all about
they're all about diversity but not
diversity of opinion or thought right
and so they want to just bully
constantly so i thought it was a great
moment to see i you know the thing it
does i i just like
it you can tell somebody sorry man i'm
sorry but uh she's a better person than
me that was some hideous for real
you've heard on this twitter that
hideous i literally would when she would
have brought that up i would have took
my phone out and be like what's your
twitter again and then i would have
wrote g-f-t-y
try put that one up on the board like
come on man like
what are we doing like that was that's
how you feel if she was qualified was to
set her up do you like you called me
hideous you would have done it
no i wouldn't have no come on i'm a
grown ass man and uh i would have i
would have done it long before
all the stuff i get by standing next to
you yes if that was the case i mean the
fact that that took up our taxpayer time
was like you weren't iowa nice and i'd
have been like well i guess i'll be
california you then how about that but i
i have to disagree i loved everything
about this moment this was one word one
like seven years ago and not only and
not only exactly
senator joni ernst is the the queen of
shade for this now she waited seven
years to she used taxpayer dollars and
she has some poor underling in the back
literally holding up
the tweet they rehearsed that this is
the most incredible thing that i've ever
seen like how could you not love this i
love the part not iowa nice yes
she wasn't iowa nice either correct
yeah i mean uh okay she was really look
i'd love to be like oh it's petty but
like two months ago my ex-best friend he
unfollowed me on instagram so i
unfollowed him back and then i went to
my cat's account and i unfollowed him
from that one and then i also unfollowed
his dog
you can't it's like you can't help it
sometimes but yeah i mean she was a
little bit too excited but also she got
nervous she was like said she wasn't
talking about her appearance which is
like that's kind of a worse right like
oh no i meant you as a person
i think that i don't know she wasn't
expecting that she wasn't expecting that
i wonder if she remembered or not she
yeah you probably if you tweet a lot you
probably wouldn't or if you're like me
when you're doing a little bit of
tippling while you're tweeting god knows
what i've said about you blizz when i'm
drunk holy crap i've enjoyed every word
this happened to me uh i told you this
story i'm not going to say who it was
because it was a famous person it was
pre-tweet i was trying to get a big star
for the show
and the person wouldn't get back to me
and then they they finally like a couple
days later uh
our booker said he wants to talk to you
and go oh this is great this is great it
was a kind of a famous so you drunk
tweeted no it wasn't a tweet he said he
loves tweet he enjoys the show but he
told me why he wouldn't do the show is
because i had insulted his wife and i
totally did not remember it but then
when he told me about it i remembered
that i had done it on a radio show oh my
god i said his wife was a terrible
actress i was like it wasn't will smith
was it yeah because it was like get
security in here right now yeah but it
was yeah but then i was like i was i
felt this was telling
but i apologize i apologize
he goes i accept your apology still not
doing yourself yeah his wife probably
wouldn't be cool with that no that's
right i think that's he was doing he was
being uh he was sitting right next to
him yeah jada smith you're on
speakerphone
i'm gonna be on gut film she went no
you're not you're not data it's not an
adjective yes it is you got jada smith
you got james yeah cheated
you got jaded
there's a great idea for a reality show
all right i gotta shut up i just saw the
highlights from it hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else